bin ich hübsch hallo mein name ist luca
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen video ihr seht es bereits im titel
eingeblendet und zwar bin ich hübsch wir
spielen heute ein test des quiz mit dem
titel bin ich hübsch das ist halt
eigentlich nur ein mädchen quiz das
heißt ich mache es trotzdem die erste
frage ist haye erstmal findest du dich
selbst hübsch hässlicher geht's nicht
nein geht so ja die hübscheste also wir
müssen jetzt quasi selbst sagen ob wir
hübsch sind siri bin ich eigentlich
hübsch das kann ich direkt ich mich
zeigen
siri sagt mir ob ich hübsch bin
siri hat mir gerade ob in russland
gezeigt den ich hübsch
ich bin schwer beantworten die frage
also mit ja klicken auf nächste frage
und die frage lautet welche augenfarbe
hast du welche augenfarbe besitzt du in
echt nicht welche du dir wünschst wieso
hat man bei kontaktlinsen keine
augenfarbe alter so gar keinen sinn so
ja sobald man kontaktlinsen trägt man
hat keine augenfarbe mehr liebe quiz
herstellerin das ganze macht wirklich
überhaupt keinen sinn ich weiß nicht ob
wir überhaupt schon mal jeden kurs
gemacht haben das wirklich sinn ergeben
hat welche augenfarbe habe ich schiebe
keine angeschlossenen geräte aber wenn
du welche einrichtet ich nicht über die
gesellschaft freuen
ich frage sie welche augenfarbe ich habe
und sie sagt sie findet keine
angeschlossenen geräte wenn ich welche
einrichtet wird sie sich darüber freuen
wir machen dass man alleine seine
augenfarbe ist so grün ja eigentlich
grün also habe ich jetzt mal grün
angeklickt werden als weitere
möglichkeiten als kontaktlinsen blau
braun eine andere gehabt aber wir
kriegen einfach auf nächste frage jetzt
welche augenfarbe hättest du gern was
ist denn das für ein quiz welche
augenfarbe hätte ich gern das ist das
resultat einer red suche jetzt google
serie noch für mich welche augenfarbe
ich bräuchte wirklich danke für deine
hilfe
du bist jetzt aber es war übrigens hier
das kissen es steht jetzt hinter und
welche eine tolle ab lager habe das
kissen falls ihr euch fragt wo er das
kaufen könnte
es tut mir leid aber ich finde den
dschungel eigentlich ganz cool und
schaut doch mal vorbei
ich wünsche mir eigentlich keine andere
augenfarbe früher wollte ich unbedingt
mal blau haben aber irgendwie ist mir
das jetzt mittlerweile auch scheißegal
also ich klicke einfach mal auf meine
ist schön klicke auf nächste frage deine
haare wie sind die supertolle frage
deine haare wie sind die meine haare
sind tatsächlich sehr haarig
außergewöhnlich rot oder so aber natur
haarfarbe geht dich nichts an außer
gewöhnlich gefärbt normal gefärbt normal
blond braun schwarz ich würde mal sagen
normal isst du schlank oder moppel ich
und dann haben jetzt außer möglichkeiten
dick dünn schlank ich bin mit meiner
figur zufrieden also ist doch egal fed
normal die sache ist ich bin mit meiner
figur zufrieden also ist doch egal
andererseits bin ich auch schlank aber
irgendwie auch ein bisschen normal siri
bin ich fett
danke für deine tolle antwort siri du
hast du nämlich einfach gesagt ist es
jetzt ja oder nein bin ich dünn
kein kommentar kein kommentar ich würde
einfach sagen wir klicken dann ich bin
mit meiner figur zufrieden also es doch
egal an weil siri meint einerseits dazu
dass ich fett bin und ist doch egal oder
ja diesem jahr das hat sie gar nicht
gesagt
komplett egal wie diese frage da
brauchst du alter to und oder 1 14
jahren in peking dabei sein ich hätte
aber gern was wir tun ein will ich auch
nicht klicke ich da mal an und bei der
nächsten frage und wie steht's mit
schönheits op liga was sind das denn für
mädchen die solche kurse sehr stark
gewesen ist es was ist eigentlich der
plural von christus hatten wir die
letzten vollen auch schon immer was
hältst du von schönheits op was kann ich
sagen ich hatte keine und will keine
wäre darauf jetzt meine antwort wie sind
deine haare wir hatten doch wohin
schauen wie sind deine haare als frage
vor allem blendet sie dann bild einen
von vier verschiedenen hauttypen und
dann kommen fünf auswahlmöglichkeiten
lady dein leben genau überdenken leben
gerät nach holz genug kreuth genug lange
an
wie findest du das mädchen auf dem bild
herzlich normal halt hübsch zum kotzen
wunderschön ich würde sagen sie es
normal also das ist jetzt kein mädchen
ruhig sagen würde okay ich würde mich
total in sie verknallt vom äußeren aber
ich finde auch immer es kommt mehr auf
den charakter an
aber trotzdem würde ich sagen das ist
ein ganz normales mädchen kommen jetzt
auch schon zur letzten frage so das war
es dann das denkst du kommt raus kann
als wenn die letzte frage einfach immer
so ein scheiß bei den anderen crysis war
die letzte frage hat immer irgendwie
sowas wie hatte das kurs gefallen wenn
man dann wahrscheinlich gesagt hat war
scheiße oder ich denke jetzt das und das
kommt raus dann ist wahrscheinlich genau
das gegenteil der fall oder man ist dann
halt zu kaffee und macht vernünftige
quiz und schreibt mir sie in die
kommentare jetzt sofort ich würde sagen
jetzt kommt raus hässlich ich bin nicht
hübsch aber wir klickt man einfach auf
auswertungen und schauen uns das an
wunderschön es kommt locker immer raus
was meine ich auch so du bist schön und
seine inneren werte sind auch super
zeigt den anderen video bist und sie
werden dich mögen das ist doch mal ein
toller abschluss fürs heutige video an
dieser stelle würde ich auch das heutige
video beenden wenn es euch gefallen hat
spam den daumen nach oben button wenn
ihr mehr testen dich kurses sehen wollt
und ansehen und im nächsten video wieder
haut mir ganz viele neue quiz und in die
kommentare
macht es dort kaum los